domingo herman will make his third start
the first two didn't go that well let's
take a look at the scouting report why
are you ready now you have not pitched
in the major league since april 10th
went down to the site to work on the
command on his fastball and here's cesar
hernandez batting left-handed
lifted in the air left center
gardner racing in makes the catch then
bobbles it and the ball pops out and
safe at first is hernandez and a gift
hit for cesar hernandez on a ball boy
you don't see brett gardner not make
that play so the indians with runners
at second and third on two bloop hits
eddie rosario the indians clean up
hitter hard hit ground ball back in and
it gets by four
that'll score one ramirez stops at third
and that's gonna be an rbi single for
eddie rosario a nice diving attempt by
ford but he could not corral the ball
ford who's supposed to be an upgrade
defensively at first
trying to make a backhanded play on a
ball that wasn't hit all that hard
he didn't show much range on that one
nothing indians runners at the corners a
pitch hit weakly back to the mound
vermont dropped the ball
he has no play in the score
ramirez
on what should have been an ending
ending double play
hermann on a little check swing roller
grabbed it
turned to start a double play with a
throw to second
drop the ball
disastrous
defensive first inning for new york and
have runners at first and second and
still only one man out now the pitch a
swing and a shot to right there's a base
hit rosario being waved home frazier's
throw to the plate slide tag safe at the
plate
it's three nothing indians
josh naylor with an rbi single to right
and the indians are saying thank you
very much to the new york yankees and
are actually taking advantage there's a
run over third with one out here's the
big at bat in this inning it's dj lemayo
to try to get the run in breaking ball
is cut on and line to left there's a
base hit
so higgy will score
and rosario throws into second it's a
base hit and an rbi for la mayhew and
the yankees now trail 3-1 this goes to
show you how good of a hitter he is
another one right there big two out
rbi it's the anchor went out rbf man
gets the yankees on the board
two on two out gleber torres he drew the
ire of yankee fans and media and last
night he hit a comebacker to the mound
and he didn't really run he was in the
doghouse
boone
talked to him after the game and the
pitch is swung on hit in the air to
right center cutting over his nailer he
can't get it and he loses the ball it
rolls away all the way to the warning
track both runs should be added to the
score they do and all the way to third
goes glamour tours and we are tied at
three i'll tell you what it's kind of an
awkward swing and you know he put the
barrel on it but he was kind of falling
away for it i think naylor got a bad
read on it
see this just kind of dunk in and then
all of a sudden ricochet off his shin
the yankees are off to the races
good break for the yankees right here
well if a hitter puts a charge into one
tonight you're going to be rewarded with
that breeze blowing out swung on and
hammered towards dead center this ball
near the wall and it is going to be up
against the wall into second reyes he's
going to turn and go for three throw to
third slide safe with a triple for the
big man
fran mill reyes with a triple to center
not sure what happened out there with
aaron hicks and brett gardner and again
not a good defensive play by aaron hicks
reyes gets a triple
runners on the corners for the indians
bidding to take the lead here in the
fourth swung on hit on the ground to
second from right field o'doro throws to
first in time
so adore was in the first base hole
and
made the play
bases loaded two out gardner has walked
struck out and grouded a third a
swinging a chopper on the
third base side ramirez has it goes to
second for the force and shaw able to
work out of it the yankees
have another great chance because now a
base it would mean two runs here is rugi
odor
swung on and grounded toward the middle
base hit center field judge scores
coming home is torres he scores it is a
two run base hit for rugey odor that's a
big hit and the yankees have missed that
hit all year long
well rugio door knocks in two and the
yankees take a 5-3 lead
and this was down on the outside corner
just got it off the end of the bat but
it counts and he did it in the empire
second base empire had to jump out of
the way and uh hernandez tried to get
that
couldn't couldn't get it
and here is kyle
hagashi oka to lead off swung on and hit
in the air to center in deep that ball
is
gone
over the center field wall
higashi oka
the home run stroka this one the dead
center you're going to be playing a lot
i think and the yankees take a 6-3 lead
with his third homework he really does
you know you put a fastball anywhere in
that zone and he will rush it
moved in on 94 miles an hour he's got
he's got a terrific swing doesn't he yes
that's what i mentioned i mentioned it
after his double he'll be playing a lot
indians got three in the first nothing
since
and they got those three in the first
bowers grounds one toward first easy
play for ford and will go to the ninth
labor tours the matter two for four
couple of singles and rbi and now it is
ripped to left field it's another base
hit for blaber torres
so maybe yesterday the criticism he
received from his manager meeting with
his manager for not running out that
ground ball
kind of woke up labor tourists he has
three hits on the night exit third
o'dour at second talkman is at first
gardner at the play yankees up by three
and a swing and a little weak pop into
shallow left
ximena's the shortstop will grab it good
job by perez faces loaded one out he got
out of it and because of that
the yankees have to bring on their
closer
and chapman ready for the o2
[Music]
and if it's cut on a missed at 101 ball
game over yankees win
yankees win
big win for the yanks down three nothing
finally put some hits together with men
on base